they swept through cities and kingdoms
riding their dead horses hunting with
their packs of pale spiders big as
hounds hey everybody its charlie we got
all kinds of Game of Thrones stuff to
break down they just announced Naomi
Watts is officially joining the cast of
the prequel series they gave a little
preview of her character so I'll break
that down and because a lot of this
prequel series is tied up in the long
night in the White Walkers we need to
talk about how they're complete their
arc full circle at the end of Game of
Thrones season 8 so we'll start with the
Naomi Watts prequel stuff because that
tease up what's happening with the White
Walkers during season 8 we're doing a
new round of the giveaway for the fire
and blood book that's coming out next
month all you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber and leave again throw
ins related comment on the video the
official news release for Naomi Watts
reads like this it says created by Jane
Goldman and george RR martin the prequel
takes place thousands of years before
the events of Game of Thrones it
chronicles the world's descent from the
Golden Age of Heroes into its darkest
hour and only one thing is for sure from
the horrifying secrets of Westeros is
history - the true origin of the White
Walkers the mysteries of the east and
the starts of legend it's not the story
we think we know so that sort of plays
into the character that Naomi Watts is
playing the official character
description reads that she's playing a
charismatic socialite hiding a dark
secret the fact that they're announcing
Naomi Watts first - also implies that
she's going to be one of the main if not
the main character but it's an ensemble
the same way that the main show is like
Danone Davis said that they went to
Peter Dinklage first to cast him for
Tyrion before they cast any of the other
actors on the show but that doesn't mean
that Tyrion is the only main character
like you have Jon Snow Daenerys which
most of the plot is focusing on during
season 8 but you still have people like
Cersei you have Jaime so you have a
large ensemble some seasons certain
characters get more scenes than others
so like early on
Tyrion used to get way more dialogue
than the other characters later seasons
relying more heavily on Cersei Jon Snow
Daenerys so it's split a little more
evenly but because of the way they
describe her being a relatively highborn
socialite person who's very charismatic
sounds very collected she sounds like
she's a member of one of the major
houses especially being that she's such
a huge name and they want to be
familiar to the main series without just
recycling plot from that so she's
probably a member of one of the major
houses that's still around in present
day and there are only a couple of those
whose complexion that she fits like she
does not look Dornish there are a lot of
people there theorizing that she might
also be Valyrian because around this
time you're seeing the rise of the
Valyrian freehold because remember they
say the transition from the Age of
Heroes to the long night meaning that
during the first season we could see the
beginning of the full-blown long night
like obviously it's a huge deal the
transition from summer to winter they've
done that in the last two seasons on the
main show like where you go to the farm
during season four with Arya the hound
beats up the farmer takes his money then
during season seven they come back and
it's covered in snow it's barely
recognizable just enough till it's
familiar and you see their bodies in the
corner and then the Hound has that brief
flashback where he remembers them the
prequel series is filming the pilot
starting in February around the same
areas where a lot of the main show of
Game of Thrones was filmed so it'll look
very familiar
but it'll be during a more winter time
of year so however fast the transition
happens it just seems like it'll be one
of the big things that they do during
season one like season 1 and Game of
Thrones obviously a couple big twists
you learn about the White Walkers in the
pilot they push bran out the window and
then the really big twist at the end was
killing Ned Stark the person that you
thought had been the main character at
the whole time so I wouldn't expect him
to repeat too many of those big twists
which is why I like the dark secret that
Naomi Watson's character is hiding
probably doesn't have anything to do
with being a secret Targaryen there are
a lot of people that are theorizing now
and I actually kind of like this theory
that she might have ties to the stark of
Winterfell
that becomes the night king that would
be the darkest of dark secrets that you
could have and if the show is only gonna
run for seven to eight seasons and we're
seeing the transition to the long night
in maybe we'll see the beginning of the
building of the wall towards the end of
the series there could be some time
jumps season to season because the
problem with history during this period
like eight to ten thousand years ago is
that so much time goes by without
specific dates being recorded they just
say oh you know the wall was built
around 8,000 years ago in the rise of
the Valyrian freehold happens sometime
between four and eight thousand years
ago there's a really big
margin of error but it's totally
possible that she could be a Valyrian
but the only other regions and kings
that were around at that time that we
know about were the Starks of Winterfell
the kings of winter the high towers the
Lannisters Garth greenhand of house
Gardner because the Gardiners ruled the
reach at that time Garth greenhand has
also talked about as being the first
High King of Westeros but history around
that period is very spotty and
unreliable they actually built that into
the pitch for the prequel series it's
not the history you think you know there
was house two randon they were the first
storm Kings the gray king of the Iron
Islands the Bolton's were around during
that period that a little while after
the rise of the Valyrian freehold is
when the rhoynish came over and formed
what is now modern-day Dorne
so obviously Naomi Watts does not look
like she could be Dornish so I'm
assuming she's not from that far south
but like I said they want to be as
familiar as possible so that's why I
like the theory that she is a stark of
Winterfell and she will have ties to the
person that became the night king we
don't know which start King it was it's
just implied that he was a stark of
Winterfell but again they're really
fuzzy on what the timeline of the series
is going to be because for the most part
the main show has moved in real time so
like you meet the Starks they age about
one year per season so unless they want
to have one of the most downer
unresolved endings you can't do the
transition to the long night and the end
of the long night all within like a
seven year time span you'd have to do
some crazy time jump which I think would
make more sense to do in the pilot so
the regular characters can age in real
time but let me know in the comments
what do you think about Naomi Watts and
which character do you think that she's
playing and what is that dark secret
that she's hiding now getting to season
8 white Walker stuff the reason why I'm
thinking that they're going to just
completely get rid of them by the finale
is is because if you think about the
prequel in the main series is existing
as part of the same story just at
different ends of the timeline the
prequel series is covering the war
between the children of the force the
first men in the more complex reasons
why they created the White Walkers why
it was the night king rebelled against
the children of the forest they lost
control and you wind up with a scenario
in present day it makes sense that they
would close that loop and they would end
the White Walkers our get rid of them
completely while also getting rid of the
rest of the children of the forest
because it seems like the
linked like that's the price they pay
for creating this thing that is ravaged
Westeros for so long even though the
reason why they created the White
Walkers was a little more noble to
protect the Earth from these invaders
that were coming in cutting down all
their weirwoods even though the first
men are complicit and all that the
children of the forest are really the
ones to blame for their creation so the
ultimate price that they pay is that
they would go extinct it makes sense
that if you're going to get rid of the
night king it's also going to be the end
of the children of the forest too so
that lord of the ring style you have a
lot of magical creatures slowly leaving
the earth and man is left to inherit and
try to figure things out on their own
although I do believe that there will be
dragon eggs Jon Snow what Daenerys will
have a child and just because they get
rid of White Walkers doesn't mean that
magic in general will leave the earth
you still have the red priests you still
have shadow binders sorcerers is just
that the children of the forest were
more attuned to the earth in the old
gods leave all your Game of Thrones
video requests in the comments below
congratulations Lord snow you're the
book giveaway winner from my last big
game of Thrones video click here to
watch Peter Dinklage talking about
season 8 and click here for my new Arya
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight